[APPLAUSE]
EMILY PUTZE: Hi, everyone.
Welcome back from lunch.
We're going to kick off the
next hour of sessions here,
focused on the theme of
pre-launch best practices.
And I'm going to go
ahead and get us started.
So my name is Emily Putze.
And I am a partner
development manager here
at Google Play who specializes
in helping developers have
more successful game launches.
So as you can imagine I'm
pretty excited to be here today
with my colleague Jonathan,
who will be coming out
to join us in a
couple of minutes
to talk to you about some trends
and tools surrounding new game
launches.
But first, before we
dive into some trends,
let's first set the stage.
And let's talk a
little bit about what's
changed in the mobile games
industry in recent years
and what that has
meant for new launches.
So first and foremost,
times have changed,
and they've changed
very quickly.
A few years ago,
the games industry
was really still in its
naciency and taking off
in terms of profitability.
And during those times, games
could be made and launched
relatively quickly.
You could make a game,
put it in the market,
see if it made any
money, and decide if you
wanted to invest further.
Today however, the market
looks very different.
The store is evolving.
Users are evolving.
And the ecosystem is evolving.
And that means that launching
a new game in today's market
looks very different as well.
So today, launching
a new game is
an increasingly risky and
expensive proposition.
Let's talk about why.
So first, competition is higher.
Launching in today's more
mature and crowded ecosystem
can be extremely challenging.
With over a million games
on the Play Store alone,
discovery is hard.
And consumers have
more choices than ever.
Development costs
today are also higher.
So today, consumer
expectations on mobile products
are extremely high.
And they churn extremely
fast when they're not
satisfied because there
are so many alternatives
available in the market.
This means that
what we're seeing
is a lot less MVP, or Minimally
Viable Product, game launches
and a lot more
upfront investment
in fully-formed
product launches--
so games with social features,
long-tail content pipelines,
events plans, you name it.
Finally, no surprise to
anyone, marketing costs
are also higher.
UA costs continue to rise.
And across the board,
what we're seeing
is less launches and
less risk-taking.
What's interesting now
is that despite all
of these changes in the
market in recent years,
for the games that they
do choose to launch,
most developers today
continue to launch games
in largely the same way as they
did three or four years ago.
So here's what we
typically tend to see.
This as something I like to
call the traditional playbook.
Concept, design, and prototype--
so look at the market,
see what's hot, go
off and develop--
a tech launch, most
likely in the Philippines,
a retention beta,
probably in the Nordics,
followed by a monetization beta
in either Australia or Canada
just before full launch.
Now, while the countries
that I just mentioned
might differ here or
there, in general,
the traditional
playbook involves
launching a new game in no more
than five to seven markets.
It means often testing
it in production.
And that means that
deployment is often
limited to only
higher-end device types
due to concerns around
stability and ratings.
Now, if this process
sounds familiar, that's OK.
It's not necessarily
a bad thing.
There's still a lot of
evidence that this process
is working well for many.
But we at Google Play
believe that, even
for the most
sophisticated developers
who have this
playbook down to a T,
that reliance on process in a
rapidly changing environment
can be pretty dangerous.
Because it can lead to a
false sense of security.
And instead, we
believe that developers
who are more focused on
process as a means to an end,
whereby they're thinking
more about what they're
trying to achieve instead of
how, exactly, they achieve it,
are generally more adaptable
and ultimately more
successful than teams who
stay static on this front.
So with that said, I'd like
to take the next few minutes
to share some high-level trends
on how game developers today
are changing their
launch playbooks
and their development playbooks.
First, because of the costs
associated with launching,
many developers are raising--
or implementing--
a more rigorous
approach to evaluating
their new games.
And they're raising
the bar that's
required for full launch.
So for instance,
a few years ago,
let's say a new
game might have only
had to secure one or
two internal evaluations
before they secured
the right to launch.
Now developers are
taking much more
of a guilty until
proven innocent approach
to greenlighting
games for full launch
and instead requiring continuous
evaluation at multiple stages
of development, creating more
opportunities for feedback
and failure, and being more
open-minded about pulling
the plug on games
that simply aren't
up to snuff at any stage
of the development cycle.
So for instance,
in the past year,
I've worked with game teams that
have pulled the plug on games
six months or even 12
months into development,
or in the late stages
of monetization testing,
simply because they weren't
confident about a game's
metrics.
Now obviously, this
is really hard to do.
But these developers
would rather pull the plug
on a mediocre game than
absorb the cost of launching
and maintaining that
game, and instead, just
focus on fewer, better launches.
Another thing that
we're seeing today
is that developers are trying
to identify bad ideas much
earlier.
So as a result, they're
doing two things differently.
First, they're testing
their new games externally
in the market a lot earlier.
And second, they're
actually changing
their technical approach
to testing as well--
so moving away from only
testing production versions
of their games to testing
beta versions first.
Now technically, both
of these approaches
allow developers to collect
the market feedback that they
need to identify bad ideas.
But beta testing
actually has a lot
of advantages to
offer developers
throughout the development
and testing cycle.
So instead of me telling you
about some of these advantages,
let's instead take a minute
to watch a video about how
a top game developer,
Big Fish Games,
is using open beta to change
the way they develop and launch
new games for the better.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Big Fish started 15 years
ago as a casual games studio.
Over the years, we
became a powerhouse
in developing mobile games
for multiple platforms.
We've been making games for
Android since its inception.
It's been great to see how
their focus on developer
tools, and also
their global reach,
has helped us make games better
for a much wider audience.
One of the great
things now is we're
able to use tools like open
beta to really get early access
and information to
allow us to actually do
more of a user-centered,
design-focused development.
- Historically we've put games
into pre-launch that we were
already very comfortable with.
And we just waited
to sort of validate
that we had what
we thought we had.
Now that we're using
open beta, we're
really willing to put a
game out there to the world
much earlier in its process.
"Cooking Craze" is a
time management game
in which you play from
the perspective of a chef.
Big Fish published
"Cooking Craze"
working with a partner named
EleFun who developed it.
This is our first free-to-play
time management game.
And it's super fun.
They really knocked
it out of the park.
- When comparing our
previous game launch
to our more recent one,
"Cooking Craze," where
we used open beta, we
saw a dramatic reduction
in crash rate,
about 21% decrease.
We also got a much higher volume
of feedback as well, about 10x.
The other thing that we noticed
based on the larger sample size
was, with "Cooking
Craze," we had no surprise
one and two-star reviews,
whereas our past game release,
we had a few that
were uncharacterized.
One of the benefits
of being in open beta
is you can still be
released globally.
This allows our marketing teams
to optimize their processes,
their paid acquisition
partners and campaigns
that they weren't able to do
in a geo-lock soft launch.
- Before using open beta, we
would pre-release our games
into a small number of
soft-launch countries.
And we would use them
to see all the metrics
that we're looking for.
With open beta, we're going
worldwide right off the bat.
And we're able to gather
data from a much wider range
of players that is much more
representative of what we'll
see when we go to
our official launch.
With open beta, we have
said, no restrictions.
Go out, go live,
see what happens.
And we're able to
react if there's
a problem instead of assuming
that there would be a problem.
- We're looking at
the core game KPIs.
We're looking at the team
that's delivering the game
and their ability to scale.
We're looking at a lot
of the metrics that
are in Android vitals.
- When we're in pre-launch, we
start by looking at retention
numbers.
Are people coming back
on the second day?
Are they coming back
on the third day?
We're typically looking
at D1, D7, D30 retention.
Then we start looking at
the monetization metrics.
Once we're comfortable
with those metrics,
then we know that it's
time to start moving
toward our official launch.
We were able to
increase our retention
numbers fairly significantly.
We went about 9 percentage
points up on D1 retention,
about 8 percentage
points up on D7,
and about 5 percentage
points up on D30.
One of the great
things about open beta
is that we're able to gather
feedback from the beta players
without having public-facing
reviews and ratings.
So we're able to fail
harder without having
negative reviews that stick
on our permanent record
for the life cycle of the game.
- My recommendation for
all developers out there
is to take a close look at
the tools in the Play Console.
We use a lot of them, and we
benefit from them tremendously.
Just in the last
year, we've changed
the way we've
developed and released
our games substantially
based on open beta alone.
[POPPING SOUND]
[END PLAYBANK]
OK.
So another trend that we're
seeing today is that developers
are increasingly using long-term
metrics as predictors of future
success--
more specifically,
long-term engagement metrics
like LTV and
long-term retention.
And what this means
is that, as a result,
not only are developers testing
their new games earlier as
we just saw in the
Big Fish Games,
but developers are also
testing their new games
for much longer than
they have in years past.
And the reason for this is
that, because they believe
that in order to
understand true user value,
that they need to understand
the long-term engagement
and retention patterns
in their games.
Now, it's important
for me to clarify
here that, when I say developers
are testing longer, that I
don't necessarily mean that
all developers out there are
running six-month betas,
although many do if they can.
But what I do mean and
that's really important
is that more and
more developers today
are looking beyond just
D7 and D14 metrics.
And they're testing beyond
D30 metrics at the very least
in order to get a much truer
sense of the future business
success of their new titles
and to make decisions
around launching accordingly.
Finally, developers
today are proactively
changing their
pre-launch playbooks
to maximize retention in
their new games at launch.
And to do this, they're doing
a few big things differently.
I'm just going to go
through them quickly.
First, they're optimizing
new-game performance
across more devices
prior to launch.
This is not only key for
minimizing early player churn,
but also to releasing to the
masses with greater confidence.
Second, developers are also
launching with enough content
to sustain their players until
their first update at least.
And they're doing this by
monitoring content consumption
during beta and planning
for full launch accordingly.
Developers are also building
social features, or at least
the foundation for social
features, into their games
earlier and earlier
than they have before.
And the reason for
this is that they
want to leverage the bonds
that social features create
between players to drive strong
retention in their new games
right out of the gate.
And finally, developers are also
testing their live ops plans
in full, end to end,
prior to launch.
So they're doing things like
running demand-side events
and supply-side sales so they
can really, truly understand
what KPIs their live ops
move and where they still
need to optimize before
they fully launch.
So now that we've covered
a bit about how developers
are evolving their
playbooks, I'd
like to introduce my colleague
Jonathan Chung up on stage.
He's a software
engineer on the go
to market tools team for
the Play Developer Console.
And he's going to talk a little
bit about how Play is building
tools that can help you launch
more successfully in today's
market.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN CHUNG: Thanks, Emily.
As mentioned, releasing
new games today
is increasingly
difficult. And Play
is committed to building
tools to help developers
with their launches.
While this is a high-level
overview of many of the tools
available today, I'd
like to take some time
to focus specifically
on some tools
that we feel will
help you evolve
your playbook by allowing
you to test differently,
test faster, and
more importantly,
de-risk your launches.
In 2015, we introduced the
alpha and beta test tracks,
which allows developers to
distribute their APKs earlier
than ever before.
Today I'm pleased
to announce, we
are launching
internal test tracks.
Internal test tracks
allows developers
to publish and distribute their
APKs in minutes, as opposed
to hours, to up
to 100 test users,
enabling teams to do rapid
iterative testing whether they
are launching brand-new
games or new features
for their existing games.
We believe, at Google Play, that
this is a truly powerful tool,
both pre- and post-launch.
Next, choosing where to
distribute your game to
is a crucial part of your
go-to-market strategy.
With country targeting, we
are now giving developers
more control than
ever before in terms
of how you want to
distribute your games
to different regions.
This feature allows you to
distribute your production
tracks to different countries
than your test tracks.
Now, why is this something
that you would want to do?
As discussed before,
many developers
like to get early feedback
before development,
before launch of the game.
And they like to do this
using tools such as close
beta or open beta with a cap.
But maybe, close
to launch, you want
to run a production soft launch.
Well, now, with
country targeting,
you can run your beta
tests in as many countries
as you want prior to launch to
gather some valuable feedback.
And once you have proven
out your early game
concept and fixed
technical issues,
you can then proceed to
production soft launch
in selected regions
while keeping your beta
alive in other regions.
This means you can keep
gathering valuable feedback
while confirming key KPIs and
building up a ratings pad ahead
of full launch.
Finally, when you're
ready, you can launch fully
with greater confidence
and less surprises.
Now that we've spend some time
talking about distribution
and testing, let's talk about
quality and performance.
As Emily mentioned, strong
game stability and performance
are key for, number
one, preventing
early player churn,
and number two,
minimizing bad
reviews for new games.
Interesting fact-- 50%
of one-star reviews
complain about app stability
and bugs on the Play Store.
Android vitals
provides an overview
of the stability of your game
alongside other key metrics
such as battery life
and performance.
It will also report
crash rates and ANRs
across a wide range of devices
and provide stack traces
in order to help
you debug faster.
Not only are Android vitals key
to helping developers address
quality issues
before launch, they
are now also a key signal
for Google Play in a number
of user-facing areas.
Our search and
discovery algorithms
favor apps in games
with strong vitals.
And vitals are now
an important part
when your app or game
is being considered
for promotional opportunities
such as the new and updated
collections, the Google
Play Awards, editors' choice
collection, and a newly-launched
Android Excellence Program.
Long story short, Play
is prioritizing vitals.
So make sure you check it out.
Pre-launch reports can also
help developers iron out
quality and performance
issues with their game prior
to launch.
Whenever an alpha or
beta APK is uploaded,
a nondeterministic bot will
crawl your game, running
on a real, physical device
in one of our test labs,
and report on a various
range of issues.
Game developers have
found a lot of value
in the pre-launch report.
90% of developers choose
not to launch their game
if the pre-launch
report finds issues.
And today we are excited to
announce that pre-launch report
demo loops are on the way.
So how does this work?
Record and upload a date
game demo loop in OpenGL,
and receive a pre-launch
report on crash and performance
metrics such as
frames per second.
These allow you to discover
rendering issues even faster
and launch with more confidence.
To wrap up, here are
a handful of takeaways
from today's session.
Remember to try beta
tests, not only to gather
early feedback about
your game, but also
to test broader and border.
Optimize new games for long-term
metrics before launching.
And remember to check out all
the Play Console's tools that
can help you with
your next launch,
including new tools such
as internal test tracks
and pre-launch demo loops.
Next, we're going
to hear from Toby
how about how to develop games
for a more inclusive audience.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TOBIAS KNOKE: Hello, everyone.
My name is Tobias, and
I'm a Google Play BD
manager based in Berlin.
Today I will talk to you
about growing your business
on Android by building for
more inclusive audiences.
At Google, we are committed
to building for everyone,
and we want to help
you in doing the same.
And for a better understanding
on how we and you can target
every potential
gamer out there, we
have been conducting research
on underrepresented groups
in gaming, starting
with women in gaming.
Today I will share our
lessons learned with you
and some recommendations
on how you
can make most out of this
opportunity for your business
on Android.
But let me first start by
introducing Frances to you.
Frances has been playing
games for a long time.
She got introduced to games by
her mother and her grandmother.
And like many people
in her generation,
she really got hooked
on mobile games
when she got her first
smartphone in high school.
Today she is playing
a lot on mobile.
And she loves to dive
into the world of gaming.
She likes to choose
a female character
if there is one available.
And she is an active member in
the New York gaming community
today.
And she is organizing
meet-ups where people
get educated about games.
But there are way more
women than just Frances
playing mobile games.
In fact, together
with Newzoo, we've
done research and found that
49% of mobile gamers are women.
So that's one half of
the total population
playing mobile games.
And even more importantly
for everyone here
in the room, what we found
as well is that 64% of women
prefer mobile over
other platforms.
Now, that's a pretty,
pretty strong fact
for mobile game developers.
And thus, this is the
critical key audience
which should be at the front
and center of your thinking
when you develop new
games or you're operating
on your existing games.
But how does this critical
audience perceive mobile games?
Of course, there's a reason
why we have been doing research
with Newzoo.
And what we found is that women
feel less as gamers than men.
So they talk less about mobile
games amongst their peers.
They also self-identify
less as gamers.
And last but not least,
they feel more regret
when paying for games.
So this is not ideal.
And probably, they do not
feel as catered as much
by the overall mobile
gaming ecosystem.
So we've asked ourself,
of course, why is that?
And to better understand
this, well, we
took a look at our very
own Google Play Store.
Because it's not only about
the supply of mobile games,
it's also about the
demand of mobile games.
And there's a strong demand
for women to play on mobile.
But when we look at the top 100
grossing games on Google Play,
we found that male characters
are featured 44% more
often on the Google Play Store.
Well now, whilst
we recommend you
to use the icon which
works best for your game
and your audience, we think that
there is an opportunity left
on the table.
And of course, icons are the
entry point for every game
experience out there.
So I think we should
be aware that this
has a significant impact when
you are targeting players
for your game.
So let's put all
this information
into some more context.
We know that 49% of all
mobile gamers are women,
but they do not feel entirely
catered by the ecosystem.
What we know as well is,
so one, the mobile market
continues to grow.
We have been hearing
this earlier.
But also, as Emily
mentioned before,
competition is increasing.
So that's why we
think, at Google Play,
why don't we think
more about broadening
the audience for the games
developers are publishing?
And by this, you can possibly
expand your current success
with your game by appealing
to more audiences.
And in the next three
slides, I will give you
some ideas on how you might
be able to achieve that.
So number one, this is
easier said than done,
but we really
encourage you to try
developing for all audiences.
And if I say develop
for all audiences,
I mean every underrepresented
group in gaming--
so gamers coming from
all ethnicities, beliefs,
and orientations.
So ask yourself, how diverse
is your audience actually?
And could the user experience be
different for certain players?
And also, do you
actually research
a bit who could be
playing your game when
you're developing a new game?
Because I know that, as
a mobile games industry,
we are super
passionate about games.
But sometimes we just
make the games we love.
But we do not think,
maybe, so much
about who will
actually play them.
So maybe that's a
thing to consider.
And also, these thoughts are
not only true from a product
perspective, but also from
a marketing point of view.
Because if your marketing
has, again, primarily only
male characters featured, or
your targeting is super narrow,
again, you might be
leaving out the opportunity
to appeal to everyone out there.
So that's one thing.
And we think that being
inclusive is important.
And it's about a
holistic approach
which covers all your
activities around your game,
whether they're
pre-launch or post-launch.
This takes me to the second
recommendation we have.
One thing to consider is
to test inclusive imagery
with Store listing experiments.
So let's take a step back and
think of your game putting
into soft launch.
And when your game
is in soft launch,
you might be figuring
out, which icon
do you want to use, how should
your Store listing look like.
And at Google
Play-- probably, you
know this-- we have
this [INAUDIBLE] called
Store listing experiments.
With Store mixed-- with
Store listing experiments,
you can basically test which
icons, screenshots, and videos
resonate best with
your audience.
So whilst user data will
decide which icon works best,
why not be inclusive
when testing it.
Because you decide which icons
are getting tested, right?
Another thing to consider is, if
you are introducing new content
to your existing
games with live ops,
you can consider maybe
adding female characters
and see if they are resonating
with the audience or not.
Just give it a try.
At least you would have
one more gamer in there,
and that would be Frances,
from the very beginning
of this presentation.
And last but not least, listen
and talk to your community.
Find and figure out if,
really, every potential gamer
out there thinks that they
have a good experience when
playing and testing your game.
Last but not least, one
thing, if we, as mobile gaming
community, want to appeal
to every potential gamer
out there, we need to think
of the development teams who
are creating the games.
So as we know from
research, only 28%
of people in the gaming
industry are not men,
meaning women or transgender.
And if we now remember,
ourselves, again,
that 49% of mobile
gamers are women,
well, I think there is a gap.
And at Google Play, we believe
that only with a diverse team
you can capture the
whole market opportunity.
You can only be able to
scale your game to everyone
out there if you have everyone
represented in your development
team.
Now, I know this is
not always that easy.
But I think this is a fact
we should all recognize
and we should think about.
At Google Play,
we are also trying
to do our fair share in this.
So we partner with the industry
to support women developers.
As an example, you can see
here, on the screenshot,
on International
Women's Day, we promoted
games developed by women
on the Google Play Store.
And obviously, I
would love to be here
next year again and
tell you that we
are promoting more games
developed by women ever before.
I would like to
conclude by calling out
Google Play's diversity
and inclusion initiatives.
So first of all,
most of the research
you have been
seeing earlier today
is based on Change
the Game, which
is our program to empower women
who play and develop games.
If you are interested
in more information,
please check out
g.co/changethegame.
Secondly, another program we are
running is Infinite Deviation.
Together with Ideas United,
we are tackling issues
in representation
in computer science.
So again, this goes back
to my previous slide
of growing diverse teams.
And this is something
we are doing as well.
And last but not least, on
International Women's Day,
we did not only promoted
games developed by women,
but we also showcased a video
which showed four founders
from around the world who
found success in developing
and creating games.
Watch this space as we
will continue our research
on other underrepresented
groups in the space of gaming,
and also to showcase
the opportunity
which lies in building diverse
teams, products, and games.
Google Play, as a
platform, is committed
to making mobile gaming
truly for everyone
by celebrating and
empowering developers
of diverse backgrounds.
As a mobile game developer,
you have a major impact
on how future mobile
games will look like.
And we hope that you can join
us in making the mobile gaming
world more inclusive, because
mobile games are for everyone.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Next is Kanan and Tom, who will
talk to you about expanding
your game to emerging markets.
[APPLAUSE]
KANAN RAI: Thanks, Toby.
Hi, I'm Kanan, and I'm part of
the Google Play team in India.
I work with game
developers in India
and abroad with a deep
focus on emerging markets.
With the continued
success of smartphones
and the rise in
internet users, we've
seen tremendous growth in
the number of online gamers
around the world, be it a
game of "Words With Friends"
with your cousins in
Vietnam or New York,
or a game of "Ludo King"
with your friends in India,
the gaming ecosystem is booming
and bringing people together.
But not all gamers enjoy the
luxury of high-end devices
and high-speed internet.
2 billion new internet users
came online in the last 15
years, many from countries
like India, Indonesia, Brazil,
and Nigeria.
Emerging markets are at the
forefront of smartphone growth
and contribute roughly to about
80% of overall growth globally.
But these internet users are
typically on sub-$150 device
with about 1 GB,
or 1 gigabyte, RAM.
But perhaps you're thinking, I
don't need to care about that.
I'm concentrated on mature
markets like the US.
Well, actually,
our research showed
that US is the
second largest market
for low-end devices
after India, followed
by Russia at number three.
So mature markets still can have
a high degree of concentration
or low-end devices.
The first thing you
should understand
about emerging markets is
that data is like currency.
Because when compared to the
average wage in these markets,
data is super-expensive.
Let me explain.
In India-- sorry, in the US--
1 gigabyte of data
typically costs about $10,
which, on average, is the wage
for about 23 minutes of work.
In Indonesia, 1 gigabyte of
data costs only about $2.80,
but it takes 316
minutes to earn.
Another interesting fact is
that, while in India, that
is one Wi-Fi hotspot
for every 3,900 users,
the global average is
actually one Wi-Fi hotspot
for 150 users.
Imagine the network congestion.
In these markets, data
is primarily prepaid.
In India specifically,
its 95% prepaid.
This means people buy fixed
amounts of data upfront,
calculating the exact
megabyte of data
they can spend in a day,
in a week, and in a month.
As a result, the data use
is extremely budgeted.
Even with the rise of
fast-speed internet,
it is estimated, even by
2020, over a billion people
will still be on 2G networks.
But large games don't only
cost internet, but also
precious space on a
1-gigabyte device.
So it's really important for
you to ration every megabyte
that you add onto your game.
Because that one MB
might make the difference
between an install
or an uninstall
in your user's device.
We at Google want
to help enhance
the experience for
users on low-end devices
where they don't have to
compromise on quality no matter
what their device and network.
We no longer want them
to feel disappointed
with entry-level devices
where things just about work.
Entry-level devices
are a critical lifeline
for these users.
It's often the only device they
have to access the internet
and play online games.
As we think about democratizing
the internet and gaming
for users around
the world, we want
you to ask yourself
three questions--
is your game playable,
affordable, and engaging?
Playable in this context
would mean asking yourself
if the game performs well in
low, intermittent, and even
offline connections.
Does it support older
and low-end devices?
Does it keep data costs
and battery consumption
low throughout the life
cycle of your game?
Over the past few months,
we have invested a lot
in trying to understand how
to approach these challenges.
We're excited to share a
framework with you which
we use within the company to
think about these problems.
The framework breaks down how we
can make games smaller, faster,
and more engaging,
and most importantly,
help you connect with the next
billion online users with ease.
We've been working closely
with game developers
to understand how they have
been tackling these problems.
And today I would like to
share the story of AppOn,
a game developer in a
town called Pune in India,
and how they grew their game
business by degrowing the game
size.
Can we have the video please?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
TOM GREENAWAY: Well, it looks
like time management games
are a hit in several markets.
Hi, everyone.
My name's Tom Greenaway.
And I'm a developer advocate
based out of Google Sydney.
As you just heard,
AppOn have found success
by exploring the opportunities
in the emerging markets.
And recently, Kanan
and I have been
working with game developers
in emerging markets like India
to identify ways they
can optimize their games
for lower-end devices.
So today I'd like to share
with you a few pieces of advice
on these topic areas.
Let's start with the APK size.
How can you reduce
the size of your game
for the emerging markets?
Well, games will typically
have some combination
of game code, libraries,
and content assets
like graphics and audio.
One way to reduce your
file size is, of course,
to tailor your assets for
different device tiers.
For example, a lower-end device
might have a smaller resolution
screen, and therefore
might not need
higher-resolution graphics.
Or the device might not have the
latest compression algorithms
such as ASTC.
So using the multiple APK
feature in Google Play,
you can actually create
variations of your APK
that are targeted towards
tiers of devices, including
the new Android Go devices.
Next is the topic
of game performance.
If your game doesn't perform
well, then logically,
users will not be enticed to
continue playing or spending
money.
So here are a few things
you can keep in mind.
If you're struggling to
hit 60 frames per second
on a particular
device, you could
try locking the
frames per second
to 30 instead for consistency.
Also, GPU overdraw is
a major contributor
to mobile performance
bottlenecks.
So try limiting the
amount of texture
blending you're forcing
the device to handle.
For example, if you have
parallax effects in your game,
you could try simplifying
or combining those layers.
And if you gain
uses complex shaders
or other intensive
visual effects,
you could try optimizing them
further or disabling them
for particular devices.
Now, as Kanan mentioned, in the
emerging markets, the cost of--
the cost of data is really high.
In fact, it's not
actually guaranteed.
So ideally, you should design
your games with offline modes
to be available for players or
to design with the expectation
of failure at least.
For example, a developer
from Australia, Not Doppler,
released a game called
"Crash of Cars,"
pictured here on the screen.
And in the game, it supports
realtime multiplayer.
But they implemented a
clever fallback mechanism
if their uses lose
internet connectivity.
If a player
disconnects, their car
is seamlessly replaced with
a bot that takes control.
And players never realize
that there was a disruption
to their game at all.
Furthermore, the Android
emulator's performance
has improved considerably
over the years
if you use x86 emulation.
And through the emulator,
you can simulate low signal
strength connections or specific
cellular connection types,
like EDGE, GSM, and so on.
So this is a great way to test
the durability of your network
design.
Lastly, there are actually
a lot of great tools
available for game developers
on Android nowadays,
such as ProGuard, which can
help you remove unused Java
classes, resources, fields,
and methods from your APK.
And GAPID, shown
here on the screen,
is really great for
viewing texture atlases
and finding GPU bottlenecks.
It works on any device,
with any GPU manufacturer,
and any version of
OpenGL or Vulkan.
Meanwhile, systrace
and simpleperf
are just great
for CPU profiling.
And Bloaty, APK Analyzer,
and Classy Shark
can help you analyze
the bloat in your APKs.
For example, there
are developers
who have used Bloaty to discover
that they could save space
in their APK by
stripping all the log
statements in their code.
Now I want to leave you
with one last thought.
I personally believe that the
core of all successful games
is gameplay.
However, great gameplay
can be impacted negatively
if a game isn't optimized for
the device it's running on.
And so it's up to
you, as developers,
to not only make great
gameplay, but to support
that gameplay with
the techniques
I've highlighted today.
And so I urge you, revisit
the recording of this talk.
And look up the
tools and techniques
I've mentioned so that
your games can perform well
on as many devices as possible.
Thank you.
I hope we have convinced you of
the potential of the emerging
markets for games.
And you can find me
on Twitter @tcmg.
Next I'd like to introduce
Stewart Miles, who
will be talking about other ways
to drive engagement and game
quality with Firebase.
[APPLAUSE]
STEWART MILES: Hello.
As Tom mentioned,
I'm Stewart Miles.
And I work with
the Firebase team.
And I'm going to be talking
about improving user engagement
and game quality with
Firebase with Nima Akhbari.
So to get started,
we're currently
at over a million
developers using Firebase.
They're building apps and games.
This is incredible momentum
since we unveiled the Firebase
platform back at
Google I/O in 2016.
Game developers have been
joining in that party.
And it's been really great.
We're really happy with that.
And so thank you
to everyone here
who has been part of that, part
of taking that journey with us.
We're really, really happy.
So what is Firebase?
If you're not
familiar with it, it's
a mobile development
platform from Google.
It brings together a lot
of our different products
to work together.
We provide a single SDK
that give you the resources
is to develop great experiences
and grow and re-engage
your audience.
Where applicable, we have
Firebase products work together
to provide an intuitive and
powerful developer experience.
I'll give you an overview
of some of the key features
and how you can use those
to grow your audience.
So first of all,
I'll get started
on some of the platforms.
We support iOS, and
Android, and the web.
We have SDKs, native
SDKs, for those platforms
for game developers as well.
My team, we maintain
C++ and Unity SDKs.
Today we're happy to
announce we've actually
added support for
development and testing
on desktop for a
subset of our features.
This includes authentication,
the realtime database storage,
and our remote
configuration tool,
which I will cover in a bit.
OK, so before you increase
your audience, with some magic,
you really need to
understand what players
are doing within your game.
So if you're selling
a premium game,
it's likely that you want
to understand whether or not
players are making it
through your entire game,
consuming all of the content,
coming back and enjoying it
in some way, shape, or form.
Otherwise, they're not
going to buy your next game.
You're not going
to make any money.
If you're selling
a freemium game,
it's likely you want to track
how many ads they're watching,
make sure that they're
coming back every day,
making sure that they're
buying those gem or coin packs,
things like that.
So with Google
Analytics with Firebase,
you can integrate our SDK.
And you can start measuring
all of this data immediately.
And it's entirely free.
So what we provide
out of the box,
we provide a dashboard
that you can start using.
We also provide the
ability to export data
into your own analytics systems.
As soon as you integrate the
SDK with one line of code,
we start collecting
events, like, for example,
the first time
your game is opened
by a user, the engagement
time of in the game,
player retention, in-app
purchases where it's possible,
and also user demographics
with very minimal effort.
You can also log your own
custom events and pipe
that all through to understand
your player behavior.
And then in addition to
this, late last year, we
released a product we like
to call Firebase Predictions.
It's currently in beta.
And what this will
do is automatically
segment your
audience into groups
using a machine-learned model.
These user groups
can then be targeted
with some other products I'll
be covering in a bit, Cloud
Messaging and Remote Config.
And they're updated daily to
keep your predictions fresh.
So the groups that
we do out of the box,
we do churn, which predicts
the users that will churn out
of your game within the
next seven days, not churn,
the group of users
who won't leave
your game within
the next seven days,
spend, the users who are liable
to spend within the next seven
days, and not spend, the users
who are liable to not spend
within the next seven days.
So using this
information, you can
start to get a picture of
how well your game is doing.
And also it can
start to give you
an idea of how you can
start targeting experiments
to retain and increase
retention with those users.
So once you've got
an understanding
of your developer--
your players--
how do you then stop
testing out ideas and seeing
if you can improve gameplay
experience or user retention?
Well, we have a framework
called Remote Config.
It enables you to
do A/B testing.
You can store any parameters
you want to change your game.
You can deploy those without
reshipping your game.
And you can-- so
for example, you
could run experiments
on in-game promotion
of in-game purchased items.
So for example, in
this case, we've
got two different
experiments running.
One way, you can get
additional shield strength
for your MechaHamster
ball for $2.
Or you could get an additional
20 hamster bucks for just $1.
And so we could A/B test this,
see which one works the best,
and then flip a switch
on the back end.
And everything will be
using whatever configuration
that we have set.
And so out of the
box, as soon as you
start using this product, we
provide our console for this.
So you can use our console.
And we also have a REST
API that we recently
released that enables
you to integrate this
into your own game
development tools as well.
So as an example, Rockbite
Games works with us
and use Firebase
Predictions to segment
their users in a way that
was not possible before.
In the past, they just
tried to segment users
based upon demographic
data and then tested
different digital
store UI layouts
based upon these groups.
But the tests are
really inconclusive.
So with predictions,
what they did,
they segmented users into groups
based upon their likelihood
to spend or not spend.
And then Rockbite used Firebase
Remote Config to deploy changes
to their digital store UI.
And what they discovered
was that if they put chests
in the top of their
store for the users who
were more likely to spend,
those users were actually
more likely to spend more
money in their store.
So it was a very, very simple
experiment that they run.
An that ended up
boosting the monetization
flows in revenue by 25%.
So just experimenting,
trying things out
is a really great way
to improve monetization.
So that's great if players
are staying within your game.
If you want-- if players are
starting to leave your game,
and your app has migrated
off their home screen,
and they're not
opening it that often,
how do you bring them back?
Well, you can push
notifications, right?
And we have a product called
Google Cloud Messaging that
enables you to do that, right?
And this enables
you-- you know, you've
seen-- you've all seen
push notifications.
You get a message, pops up
at the top of the screen.
And that can potentially
reengaging users.
So what we do out of the box,
we provide a composer for this.
So you can have your
marketing teams,
like non-engineers, sit down,
and compose campaigns, and run
campaigns through dashboard.
And there's also a REST API.
So if you have your own live
ops tools or marketing tools,
you can do integrations
into there.
You could also potentially
automate campaigns
from your back end.
So if you run events, you could
send messages out to users
and try and bring them
back into your game.
After you've sent out
messages, obviously, you
want to see whether or
not they are effective.
So we also provide measurement
out of the box with this.
And so this is an
excellent example
of a case where using
different products together
within the Firebase suite
will pull them together.
In this particular case, it's
using our Google Analytics
product.
So if a user comes
back into your game,
it's liable that you
want to drive them
to some content within the game.
So what you can do
with notifications
is you could potentially connect
a notification to a link.
And if the user doesn't
have the game installed,
you could even have
a user share a link
with a friend to try and bring
that friend into the game.
And so using Firebase dynamic
links, you can do that.
And you can tailor the link
behavior based upon the state
that the game is on
the user's device.
So if the game isn't
installed on a user's device,
you could bring
them to a web page.
If it's installed onto
the user's device,
you could bring them
actually into the game.
If it's not installed,
you could have it
so that it installs the
game and then brings them
into the right
point in the game.
And there's many different
interesting use cases
that you can use here.
So we'll go for a
really simple one.
So we built this small demo
game called MechaHamster.
You can design your own maps
as a player within the game.
And then, you know, in
this particular case,
I've created a map, and I want
to share it with my friends.
So I create my map in this map
editor, press the Share button.
I select some friends
to share with.
I write a message, run through.
I've shared the link.
My friend receives an email.
When they tap on the link,
it actually goes through
and will open the game.
And it will show-- it
will show the content
for the user in that
game, all right, that I've
shared with one of my friends.
If they haven't got
the game installed,
it will take them through
the app install flow.
And after the app
is actually opened,
it will just open in the
correct point in the app.
There's no need to go back, find
the link in the email, which
you've probably forgotten
about after you've
installed it, to
actually continue through
to that content.
So if users are creating
this content within the game,
it's very likely you
want a way of being
able to store that content
within your gaming back end.
You could write your
own custom back end,
or you could just, again,
use Firebase, right?
You could use-- so if you
use our authentication system
to get an identity
for the user, then
you can start associating
additional data with the user.
So our authentication
solution enables
you to associate a
single identity--
so one identity for your game--
with different login providers.
So someone could log in with
Twitter, Facebook, Google.
Or today we just--
we just released support for
Google Play Games as well.
So on Android, you could
do seamless sign-in, which
is really low-friction sign-in.
As soon as the user
opens the game,
they're automatically signed in.
You can take that
sign-in, and you
can associate that with
a Firebase authentication
identity.
Now, with that identity,
you could then store data
in our realtime database.
And this can-- this is
realtime in the sense
that it synchronizes data
across all devices listening
to a point in the database
within about 100 milliseconds.
This could be used to build
collaborative editing tools.
Like, for example, in
our MechaHamster game,
we have a map editor.
And you can modify
map, and other users
can see changes in real time.
Or you could build
realtime-- you
could build turn-based
multiplayer games
and things like that as well.
If you need to store
large amounts of data--
so for example, you're
pushing new asset packs out,
or you're doing things like
allowing users to upload
user-generated content that's
large, or like, for example,
if they're creating new
art assets within the game,
or they're sharing screenshots
and things like that--
we have a product
called Firebase Storage.
Again, with that
authentication token
that we provide with
Firebase Authentication,
you can upload
user-specific data.
There's also a whole rule
system that can be applied.
And it's, again, with no
server-side programming.
You just write a
little bit of script,
and you can limit the access to
data stored in Firebase Storage
to a set of users.
So this could be
used, for example,
to send out premium content
to the users who are subscr--
who just purchased it, for
example, or are subscribers.
So again, following
the theme of not
having to bring up
your own back end,
we also offer integration
with Google Cloud Functions.
This enables you to do
things like associate
and take an event that
happens in your game, run
some logic that then
controls whether or not
an action can occur.
So I'll give you an example.
So for example, if a
devel-- if, in your game,
a player plays through
10 different levels,
and then you want to reward them
with something, you could have
a Firebase function actually
track that user's progress.
And then once they
hit-- you know,
they've completed five
or 10 different levels,
you could then
send them a reward.
And the reward could
be a modification.
You could surface that
for a modification
in the database,
which then unlocks
something in their inventory.
Or it could be
something like you
send them a push
notification to try
and get them back into the game.
They've played
through five levels.
Perhaps you send them
a push notification
that tells them, hey,
come back to the game.
Come and consume more content.
OK, so now Nima's going to
come up and talk about testing
with Firebase Test Lab.
[APPLAUSE]
NIMA AKHBARI: Breeze through it.
STEWART MILES: Sorry, mate.
NIMA AKHBARI: Thank you.
Hi, I'm Nima.
I'm from the Firebase
Test Lab team.
And I want to talk about
testing for mobile games.
So game developers
know that testing
is a critical part of
releasing a high-quality game.
But we realize that
testing games on Android
can be challenging.
The Android ecosystem has done a
great job of enabling diverse--
device diversity.
This is why Android devices
are expanding so quickly
in emerging markets.
With all these devices, it's
not reasonable for most game
developers to go out
there and buy them all.
And even if you had
all those phones,
manually testing would take a
lot of time and a lot of money.
That's where Firebase
Test Lab comes in.
We've built a lot of
labs that host a growing
number of 80 unique devices, a
mix of physical, real devices
and virtual ones.
We help you run
different types of tests
across all these devices.
And with our
command line client,
it's easy to integrate FTL with
your continuous integration
systems.
This way you can be
confident in every change
you make to your game.
I can already hear
your saying, but Nima,
testing games with
Android's provided
testing libraries is hard.
We've heard you.
And we've been working with
different gaming partners
to create the following
testing solutions.
If you don't have any
tests, no problem.
Our Robo team has been
focused on games testing
and, as a first step, has
made it possible for Robo
to test games with
random actions.
Now, when Robo encounters
a non-native UI,
like most games are, it
will send many touch actions
per second, exploring the game
while collecting performance
data, video, and screenshots.
As for any app, you only need
to provide your game APK.
And here you can see
Robo playing "Zushi."
It's playing it pretty well.
Last year at I/O, we announced
game loops, our first testing
framework for games.
With game loops, you
can write test scenarios
inside your native code.
No need to work outside
your normal environment
or write any Android Java code.
You can write custom
results that matter to you,
and we'll grab them off the
phone for you to analyze.
This year we're happy
to announce that,
after working with the Play
pre-launch report team,
in a matter of weeks, the
pre-launch report will
automatically run your game
loops for free when you launch
in the--
when you launch your app in
the alpha and beta channels
in the Play Console.
To get started, we have a
Unity plug-in as well as
a code lab that walks you
through the process of adding
game loop.
NetEase is one of the top
gaming companies in China.
They've released more than
150 mobile games since 2014
and have run several top PC
games in the last 10 years.
We reached out to
NetEase to learning more
about their testing solution.
They ensure a high
quality of all their games
through a dedicated IDE, which
helps them create and run
automated tests.
We worked hard with
them to publicly
launch this framework
for all developers to use
and to automate
tests for the games.
So to help me demo
this IDE, please
welcome Xin, the technical
director of NetEase Games,
here to help me demo.
[APPLAUSE]
Great.
So Xin here has the NetEase IDE.
And it's already connected
to his device right here.
And with this, you
can actually interact
with the device within
the IDE and use this
as the main method of
creating your test.
The IDE allows you to select
different parts of the screen
and use that with simple actions
like touch, swipe, weight,
sleeps, and different
visual asserts.
So now you can
create a simple test.
And at this point, we
have no SDK integrated.
And this is all
with just a game.
We've asserted that our hero,
our little fish, is there.
And now we can start the game.
And if you need to interact
with more complex 3D elements,
you can add an
instrument to your game
with an optional
SDK called Poko.
And we've already done
this with this game.
And so we're able to
interact with the joystick.
And as you see here, Xin
is now selecting our skill.
And we'll be moving
the joystick around.
And then that will
complete our test.
What NetEase does
here is that they
have the images that we take.
And they're able to
do image comparisons
on the runtime
screen and determine
if that object exists.
And if it does, it'll
actually click on it
or do the action
that's provided.
So we'll go ahead
and run this test.
Great, it's run through.
And now it's moving our
fish character around.
And our test is complete.
So NetEase generates a custom
report that we can look at.
And in this custom
report, you can
see a couple of cool things.
So it shows you what has
passed and what has gone wrong.
And you can see the
target object which
was the target for
the action as well as
a runtime screenshot
that NetEase takes
at each of these action points.
So you can ensure that
it fails or passes
at certain points
in your script.
Now that we've
created a script, we
want to run it on a
bunch of Android devices.
So we can bundle it
as a instrumentation
APK for Android.
And we've already
done this, so we
don't have to go through
this whole process.
So with this
instrumentation APK,
you can add it to
Firebase Test Lab
and run it on all
of our devices.
So here in the
console, this is where
you would see all of
the Firebase products.
Now we don't have
internet it looks like.
OK.
Well, we would have to upload
the APKs, which we've already
done here.
And we can skip to
device selection.
So here we have our
library of devices
that you can select through.
And we have different
devices like a Pixel phone,
Samsung phone.
And you would go through
and select which devices
you would want to run through.
And at the bottom, you can do
more advanced configurations,
like which
orientations, as well as
different locales that can
actually happen on the device.
We take all this
information, and we
use it to run your test, the
test that we just created,
on all those devices.
Do we have internet?
OK.
Let's just-- so we'll just
get straight to the results.
I don't think we have
the results preloaded.
But here you can see
that we ran the tests.
And the tests have
some that passed
and some that failed on the
specific devices that we ran.
And we can dig in deeper.
Oh great, we have internet.
We can dig in deeper.
And here we show you
the logs from the logcat
that we pulled off of
the Android device.
And you can use that to
debug if there's any issues.
And we also collect
performance data at no cost.
The video-- so there's a
whole video of the test run.
And our performance data
shows you CPU, memory,
and network usage across this
run, and soon to be, FPS.
And this is in time
with the video itself.
So if we can actually
go back to the slides--
thank you, Xin, for
helping with the demo.
[APPLAUSE]
You can-- you can get
started with this IDE today
at airtest.netease.com and
use it with Firebase Test Lab.
Hopefully testing on games
just got a lot easier.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]